WILL COME TO ORDER- I HAVE. A
DESCRIPTION OF THE CODE RELATED
PROCESS ITEMS THAT THAT I READ
EVERY HEARING AND I'M ALSO
GOING TO HAVE A BRIEF COMMENT
ON HOW WE WILL MOVE THROUGH
TODAY'S SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PROCESS IS.
SO IN RESPONSE TO COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND ALL MEMBERS WILL BE HERE
TODAY THE CENTRO TROUBLED
HASN'T ARRIVED YET BUT WE
EXPECT HER SHORTLY. SENATOR
MAYOR MEN IS PRESS HERE ME. OF
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED
THAT ANY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURED IN THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS. WE'VE MEASURED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS- TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY WE ARE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND THE
BACKUP ROOM IS ROOM ONE TWELVE.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT'S
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT AT
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
FOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIGHT TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. IN A MOMENT I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE AND EXPLAIN THE
PROCESS FOR THE HEARING FOR A
QUORUM HAS ARRIVED SO I'M GOING
TO ASK. THAT YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR LARRY HERE.
SENATOR MEN HERE SENATOR OF
TROUBLED HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU ALL THREE MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT WE HAVE A QUORUM. NOW
ON THE PROCESS TODAY THIS WILL
BE THE FINAL SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING PRIOR TO JUNE
FIFTEENTH. AS TODAY AT TODAY'S
HEARING THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
CLOSE OUT MANY ITEMS RELATED TO
K. THROUGH TWELVE. EARLY
EDUCATION AND HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT WE HAVE HEARD AND DISCUSS.
THROUGH THIS. BOB THERE ARE FEW
I THAT STILL IN. SENATOR MEN
COULD YOU CLOSE THAT DOOR THANK
YOU. THERE ARE A FEW ITEMS THAT
ARE STILL IN DISCUSSION AND
WILL BE ACTED ON THE FULL
COMMITTEE HEARING NEXT WEEK AND
SO IF YOU DO NOT SEE A FINAL
DECISION HERE. ON A PARTICULAR
ITEM. IT WILL BE DECIDED IN THE
FALL BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING
NEXT WEEK THERE ARE FEW ITEMS
STILL UNDER NEGOTIATION THAT
WOULD BE IN THAT CATEGORY.
TODAY WE HAVE TEN ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
HEARD EXACTLY AS THEY ARE AND
THE REMAINING ITEMS ARE VOTE
ONLY SINCE IN OUR PREVIOUS
TWELVE HEARINGS A PARTICULARLY
THE TWO LAST WEEK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WE HAVE
HEARD THEM I WILL HEAR THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS FIRST AND
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE AT THE
END OF THE HEARING ONCE WE'VE
COMPLETED THESE DISCUSSION
ITEMS. ARM N. AND AFTER THAT WE
WOULD RETURNED- TO THE AGENDA
ITEMS FOR IT- ON THE DISCUSSION
ONCE IN A DISCUSSION AND VOTE
BUT I THINK THAT THAT THE WAY
WE WILL OPERATE TODAY IS TO
ATTEMPT TO TAKE THEM AS A GROUP
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE ONE MOTION
AND WE CAN HEAR IF ANY F THE
SENATORS WISH TO VOTE NO OR
WISH TO OF STAIN ON ANY OF THE
ITEMS AND WE MIGHT DO THOSE IN
TWO BLOCKS SO WE DO A BLOCK
WHERE. WE ANTICIPATE THERE'S
UNANIMITY AND A BLOCK WHERE WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE'S NOT
UNANIMITY SO THAT WE CAN RECORD
ALL THE VOTES- ARE ACCURATELY
AND WE HAVE TO RECESS IF WE ARE
STILL GOING AT NOON AND SO IF
THERE IS EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT I MIGHT LIMIT TO IT OF
THE TIME THAT WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT JUST SO THAT. OUR
WEEKEND DEAL WITH ANY VOTES ARE
IN TIME FOR OUR NOON RECESS IN.
THE IDEAL WORLD SINCE. SINCE
ALMOST ALL THAT TIME OF THESE
ARE ARE FOR OR MONEY THERE'S AN
OUT CHANCE WE CAN FINISH NOON.
BUT IF NOT WE WOULD COME BACK
RECESS AND SCHEDULED TO COME
BACK AT ONE ALTHOUGH WE WOULD
SEE. WHEN PEOPLE ARE CAME BACK
AND DO IT BUT THAT IS OUR
PROCESS FOR TODAY SO SENATOR OF
A CHOI BOGUE OR SENATOR MEN DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS HEADING INTO THIS.
THEN LET'S BEGIN THE HEARING.
ARM WILL START. WITH THE AGENDA
PART A DISCUSSION ISSUES OF ONE
TO TEN. AND PRESENTING WILL BE
EDGAR CABRAL OF THE L. WYO WE
DO HAVE HERE. ARE PEOPLE OTHER
PEOPLE FROM THE LION'S FINANCE
OF FOR ANY REASON. OUR OF THE A
R. DID TO SAY ANY HELLO FOR THE
TEN BUT THAN THE- THEN WARM.
HER TO ANY QUESTION OF MS
CABRAL AND MOVED TO PUBLIC. SO
WITH THAT A MISTER WELCOME TO
THE. MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT WITH
LIPS WITH A- SOURCES AFTER
THROUGH- AND BRING DESCRIBE THE
FOR THAT CAN BE FOR OF THE-
ITEMS ARE ON THE DISCO BOTH.
AND- I MEAN AND I'M MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN HELP ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. SO
JUST GO THROUGH BRIEFLY. AND
THEN WALK WITH IS YOU REMEMBER
WRITE THEM. THE STUFF DAKOTA
THEN IF WERE THE MOST
PRIVILEGED THE SCRIPT THAT.
CONCENTRATION GRANT WITH THE
PRIEST THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
FROM TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
POINT 3% OF THE BASE. OF THE
STUFF COMMISSION WILL ALSO
ADOPTED SOLUTION OR BUILDING
WHICH- WOULD SPECIFY THAT THE
INCREASING FUNDING OUR CAN ALSO
BE USED INCREASE. THE. NUMBER
TWO IS RELATED LEARNING TIME TO
THE- OF HOLD UP FOR AND ONE
BILLION. IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
AND LITTLE MAKE UP TO FIVE
BILLION TO PROVIDE. SUMMER
AFTER SCHOOL UP TO. IT'S
DISTRICT ARE. YOU KNOW THAT-
THAN 55% OUR STUDENTS ARE LOW
INCOME YOUR THE U. BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF. KNOWING THE OFFICE
YOU STUDENT IN GRADES K.
THROUGH SIX NUMBER THERE WILL
BE A MINIMUM GRAPH DOLLAR
DOLLARS AND THERE WILL BE
REQUIRED THAT FAMILIES HAVE.
LOOK THE OFFICE USED THE THIRD.
BY THE ONLY A- AND THE PROPOSAL
WOULD THEN- OVER THREE YEARS TO
BILLION. FOR SHE- I REMEMBER
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
MEMBERS HAD A POINT OH PER CALL
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION- THE
DISCOVER COMMITTEE HERE IS TO-
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING. FOR SPECIAL.
THE FIRST ARE LOOKING FOR ME TO
PER A FULL POINT 0% TO
OBSTACLES ARE AMONG STATE MY
RATE UNDER THE MAYOR DID YOU
KNOW RECEIVE A CUSTOM. IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION LEARNING
RECOVERY GRANT WOULD BE FUNDED
WITH ONE TIME FEDERAL STUDENT
FUNDS AND WOULD BE USED FOR
LEARNING SO FOR STUDENTS WITH
THIS. WOULD REQUIRE THAT WOULD
BE FUNDS ON ONE TO ONE BASIS-
DATA THERE BE ON. ALTERNATIVE
THEORIES PRACTICE IN- B. R.
PLANS TO ENGAGE FAMILIES THE
SLAIN AND OTHER TO PURCHASE IN
EDUCATION PROCESS. I DON'T FIVE
MILLIONS BEFORE IT'S SPECIAL.
EARLY IN. QUESTION INCLUDE
PACKAGE. THERE ARE TWO PIECES
ONE IS TWENTY DOLLARS A ONE
TIME YOU. THAT COULD BE USED
OVER THE YEARS THE SAID IT
BECAUSE PARK PROJECT. ON WHICH
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE AND GRANTS
VALLEY EIGHT THEIR INCLUDES
PRACTICES. I'M IN A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. SIX IT IS THE
CORRECT TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM THIS IS
A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL AS WELL
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION ONGOING
PROPERTY GENERAL FUND. THIS
WOULD BE A DOUBLING OF THE SIZE
OF THE PROGRAM AND TO INCREASE-
THE PRIORITIZATION OF THE
PUBLIC CONSIDERATION FOR
EXISTING- HIGH QUALITY REGIONAL
BASED. PROGRAMS SUCH AS THOSE
RUN BY THREE POWERS AGENCIES.
OR THROUGH A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I HAVE SEVEN IS ALSO
LISTED. WITH THE V. EIGHT THREE
G. R. AND OR IN GRANT PACKAGE
THERE ARE TWO COMPONENTS HERE.
IT'S TOTALING SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ARE ONE
COMPONENT IS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO
ALLOF THESE TO IMPROVE A THREE
G. COMPLETION RATES. THROUGH
FAST TRAINING OUR PEOPLE
SUPPORTS OR INCREASING ACCESS
TO EIGHTEEN G. COURSES OR TO
COVER IF YOU COMPLIMENTS.
CHRISTMAS EVE. AMID THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR WOULD BE
FOR HIGH SCHOOL LEARNING LOS
CONTENDER WITH THE AS LONG
STUDENTS TO RETAIN A KEY
COURSES THEY DID NOT PASS. A
RECOVERY TO HE MY SCHOOL. BACK
IN THE NUMBER BE I'M THIS WILL
BE FUNDED- THE AMOUNT. DIEM
BASED ON THE TIME. NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME YOU KNOW. STUDENTS
IN GRADES. FOUR NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT IS THE SMOKING THE
MADE ME VISIBLE HERE TO MAKE
ACTION THE SMOKING REGARD-
AVAILABLE FOR ALL YOUR BY THE-
FOUR FIVE. YEAR ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HERE TO FIX YOUR-
BY WAY OF THIS YEAR SO THAT
WILL ARE ACCESS WOULD NEED
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND
THEN THE ADDRESS WILL
REQUIREMENTS. OF THE PROGRAM BE
A FULL SCHOOL DAY- THE
PRETTIEST OPERATIONAL. STAFF TO
STUDENT RATIO OF ONE TO TEN.
OUR DATA THE PRESCHOOL OF. ROCK
COULD BE USED FOR THE OUT AND
SUMMER SCHOOL CARE FORTY K.
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS. AND
FINALLY TO ALLOW PARENTS CHOICE
FOR OUR CHILDREN SO THAT.
CHILDREN WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
TEACHING COULD INSTEAD. BE
ENROLLED IN HEAD START PROGRAMS
OR A- DIFFERENT SHELTER. IN THE
LAST TWO ITEMS HERE ARE ARE.
RELATED TO SEE PRESCHOOL THE
FIRST- ITEM NINETY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOINGPROBLEM THE GENERAL
FUND TO INCREASE ADDITIONAL ON
A FULL DAY FULL YEAR SPOTS
ELOISE. I'M IN THE NUMBER TEN
IT IS TO PROVIDE RATE INCREASES
TO THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
BUT IT WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION FUNDING THE
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- INCREASING TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING. ON THE
NOMINEE GENERAL FUND OF THIS
RECORD WE HAVE PROBABLY THE
GENERAL FUND IS USED FOR THE
PRESCHOOL ELOISE MONAGHAN THE
GENERAL FUND IS USED FOR THOSE
RUN BY ANOTHER LEAVES COVER THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
I'M NOT NINETY FIVE THAT WOULD
BE A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION. IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
THEN BACKWARDS. TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE MILLION ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY. AMONG OTHERS THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO. RATE
INCREASE. BOB MARLEY OF THE IS
REALLY. THERE WE ARE US THE
THIRTY THE WORLD ACTION. WILL
BE HEARD ON SENATE'S THREE TO-
BACK- RELATING TO OUR- HEALTH
CARE REFORM. BOTH ARE VERY ME
MICHAEL ARE HERE IS AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY YOUR
PRESENT AND I WOULD KNOW- AGAIN
WHICH SAID ON ITEM TO. THAT
THIS CONFORM RELATED ACTIONS ON
CHILD CARE RATE REFORM TO BE
HEARD IN SOME COMMITTEE THREE
TOMORROW SO THAT TO I THINK IT
BEGINS TO SUNSHINE HOUSE SOME
OF THIS FITS TOGETHER. THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS OF MR CABRAL ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. I AM. AS
SENATOR MYSTIC AND MAKE SURE
YOU YOU MIGHT CONSIDER.
UPPERSIDE I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
ON THE HARD WORK THAT WENT INTO
THIS- ON ITEM TWO EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME I. APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS WAS REVISED TO
REFLECT SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE
RAISED IN OUR LAST HEARING.
AROUND ELEAZAR LIKE MANY IN MY
DISTRICT THAT HAVE SOME LOW
INCOME STUDENTS BUT MAY NOT HIT
THE 55% OR OTHER THRESHOLDS
NEEDED TO. RECEIVE FUNDS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I THINK
THIS IS MORE EQUITABLE
PROMOTION I APPRECIATE- THE
CHANGES I ALSO WANT TO ECKERD
ECHO GERMAN THERE'S POINT ON
THE- RATE REFORM. THAT IS GOING
INTO ITEM TEN WITH STATE
PRESCHOOL I THINK PER CHILD
EARLY CHILD CARE IS OBVIOUSLY
AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY. I THINK
REFORM IS GOING TO BE NECESSARY
I APPRECIATE THIS- I GUESS MY
ONLY QUESTION IS. HOW
SUSTAINABLE IS THIS COMMITMENT
TO EARLY CHILD CARE AND T. K.
IF WE WERE TO HIT ANY KIND OF
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN- A FEW YEARS
OUT. I THINK IT'S A TERMS OF
THE ENEMY TERMS OF WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- I AM I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HEADED TO
REVENGE THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. GUARANTEE SO THAT- THOSE
COSTS WHEN ASSEMBLY BE COMING
OUT. OF THE THREE PROBABLY NEED
POLICY GROWING TO COVER THOSE
ADDITIONAL COSTS. UNTIL THEY
WERE REPORTED THROUGH THEM THE
PROBABILITY FORMULA ON THE
OTHER SOCCER RATES WOULD BE
THROUGH SORT OF NON PROBABLY
NEED GENERAL FUND. I THINK WITH
ALL THESE THINGS BIG- THERE'S
ALWAYS.A RISK THAT IF WE DO
HAVE AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT
THERE'S LESS FUNDING AVAILABLE
I THINK I A BIG PART OF THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THOSE RECORDS
THAT DEPENDS ON. YOUR OVERALL
PACKAGE WELL WHICH I DON'T
THINK WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DETAIL TO SORT OF. FULLY- BE
ABLE TO GIVE YOU AN ASSESSMENT
OF HOW MUCH OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
IN THE- SENATE PACKAGE ARE
ONGOING HOW DOES THAT COMPARE
TO FOR EXAMPLE OUR MULTI YOUR
OUTLOOK. ON BUT IT BUT IT IS A
APPOINTED AS YOU ARE QUITE SOME
OF THESE RATE INCREASES IT-DOESN'T MEAN THAT. YOU'RE
INCREASING YOUR ONGOING
CONFLICTS OVER TIME- TO THE
EXTENT THAT REVENUES ARE
PROJECTED TO GROW TO COVER
THOSE COSTS IT'S ENOUGH OF A
CONCERN- BUT IF YOU HAVE AN
ECONOMIC. DOWNTURN WITH A WITH.
A RISK. I APPRECIATE MISTER-
AND I GUESS I JUST ENJOY BEFORE
YOU GO. YOUR EARNED A-
MAGICALLY APPEARED OWNERS. NOT
HAND AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MEANT YOU. TO GO. OR YOU WERE
JUST GET YOUR TIME IN THE SUN.
MORNING RESEARCHER NO I IT WAS
NOT DOING THAT BECAUSE I WANTED
TO COMMENT JUST. MAKING SURE
THAT- I WAS READY IN CASE- YOU
ALL WANTED TO HEAR FROM US I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE FOR NO NO NO
NO LEARNING IN MY PRESENCE
THERE NO. PROBLEM WHATSOEVER I
KNEW YOU WERE HERE ANYWAY A
SENATOR MINNESOTA STUDIO
JESSICA COULD I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER- AND- YOU KNOW I THINK
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CHILD CARE
IS OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT LONG
TERM INVESTMENT THAT WILL IN
THE LONG RUN I BELIEVE. BE
BETTER FOR OUR ECONOMY BETTER
FOR LONG TERM TAX RECEIPTS BUT-
I WE ALL OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY. THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
JOE BOAN COMMENTS. JUST A-
JUST EXCITED TO SEE THE ERA-
THE N. TEN ITEM NUMBER TEN ON
THE STATE SCHOOL PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM REFORM- GRATEFUL TO BE
AN HONOR TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
SB TWO FORTY SIX A GRATEFUL TO
SEE THAT ON HERE WELL THAT'S
GREAT I THINK WERE. UNITED AND
EXCITEMENT ON THAT I SO IT'S
GREAT OF THEN WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE TO COMMENT ON ITEMS ONE
THROUGH TEN WE HAVE HEARD THE
OTHER HUNDREDS OF ITEMS OVER
OUR PREVIOUSTWELVE HEARINGS SO
THIS IS JUST ON ITEMS ONE
THROUGH TEN. AND I'M GOING TO
LIMIT IT TO ONE MINUTE AND THEN
IF THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
CONFERENCE ALL OF LINE ALL
DECIDE IF THERE'S A LIMIT TO BE
DONE THERE. SO FIRST LET'S GO
TO FUND THIS ROOM ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE DOES ANYBODY
WISH TO COMMENT. SAYING NO ONE
I'M GONNA GO TO ROOM TWELVE ONE
TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE MODERATOR-
THIS IS TO YOU. AND I WAS GONNA
ASK ONCE YOU ANNOUNCE AND
THINGS- HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
QUEUED UP. THE MODERATOR
WELCOME TWELVE WELL WITH. YEAH
WITHOUT GIVING ANY INSTRUCTIONS
AT ALL WE ARE WE HAVE TEN IN Q.
OPERATE INSTRUCTIONS AT THIS
TIME PLEASE IN GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU LIKE TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE TO
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS HEARD PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE THAT'S TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING- OUR NUMBERS BUT WE SEE
A PRESIDENT THAT VOICE BUT WE
SUPPORT THE MODIFIED PROPOSAL
TO INCREASE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION FUNDING BY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
OF COURSE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED ACTUALLY BY DONALD
TRUMP THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OUR MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE EIGHTEEN IF YOU CAN
CHECKYOURSELF FOR SELF MUTE WE
HEAR AN AUDIO. DURING A
RESPONSIBLE MOVE ON THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX THAT'S TWO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE. OKAY HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY AND I AM THE RESURGENT
QUALITY MANAGER- AND I AM
CAUGHT UP FROM IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND I'M CAUGHT
COMMENTING ON ITEM NUMBER TWO
OF THE AGENDA. I WORK AT A BIG
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE WORK WITH
THAT HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ASKING
YOU TO INVEST FEDERAL CONSTRUCT
WE IN COMMUNITY BASED.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING AFTER SCHOOL LEARNING
AND SUMMER ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL WELLBEING AND
XCELERATED LEARNING OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL WE ARE FACING AN
ENORMOUS CHALLENGE AND WE KNOW
THAT COOL CANNOT DO IT ALONE.
THIS REQUIRES ALL HANDS ON
DECK. BASICALLY WE ARE ASKING
YOU TO SET. ASIDE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS SHOULD BE
MADE. DIRECTLY AVAILABLE TO
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE YOU TO
PROVIDE A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FROM THE C. O. L. A.
FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
AND SAFETY PROGRAM AND TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS. USING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING- YOU VERIFY. YOUR VIC
SEEDED THEM THE MINUTE BY ABOUT
TEN SECONDS TO A MINUTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOU
CAN EXTEND YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. YES AND AS A
REMINDER HAVE. STERLING Q.
PUBLIC. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO SIX THAT'S TWO SIX OR ONE
IS OPEN. IT APPEARS THEY HAVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE OR GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN TO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ENGINE AT PELLETIER I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. I'M CALLING THIS
MORNING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR ITEMS THREE FOUR
FIVE AM FOURTEEN. REGARDING
ITEM FOR THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION
LEARNING RECOVERY GRANTS AND
COSPONSORED EIGHTY NINE SIX
SEVEN WEEKS OF COURTNEY
INCLUSION OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PURPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THAT'S ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A LINE SEVENTEEN
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. EXCELLENT I MEAN
COMMITTEE WELL I'M GLAD YOU CAN
HEAR ME BECAUSE I CERTAINLY
COULDN'T HEAR THE FIRST WITNESS
BECAUSE YOUR TECHNOLOGY IS
COMPLETELY UNLAWFUL WEEKEND
ADEQUATE I COULDN'T HEAR WHAT
HE SAID IT WOULD SELL PROBABLY
GARBLED AND YOU PEOPLE WANT TO
RUSH. BY NOON AND LIMIT FOR THE
PEOPLE IT SEEMS TO ME YOU NEED
A REMINDER CONCLUDE MY FINAL
FOR THE SECOND READING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND RESTORE
MAJOR. REJECTS YOU FOR YOUR-
RELIGION. OVERBRIDGE THE FREE
OF SPEECH. THE PEOPLE PEACEFUL
WITH THE I DID THE GOVERNMENT
FOR A REDRESS OF GRIEVANCES.
MONEY IS SHOWING YOUR- SO YOU
CAN A LITTLE CLOSE AND YOU'LL-
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE A
MINUTE I WAS GONNA ASK YOU TO A
DE YOUR BUT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE CALL THANK FOR YOUR CALL
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
CALLER SOMEONE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THAT'S ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THANK YOU- THIS IS ADAM
STEIN I REPRESENT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SONOMA COUNTIES HELP US.
AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
ITEMS THREE FOUR AND FIVE TODAY
AND EVERY OTHER SPECIAL
EDUCATION ITEM IN THE PACKAGE-
AND I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTIVELY RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS. BACK WE INCREASE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS KNOWING WHAT THE COSTS
ARE GOING TO BE OUR PRELIMINARY
DATA SHOWS THAT AFTER MINIMUM.
CROFTERS COOL DISTRICT FOR
MAKING UP FOR LOST LEARNING.
STUDENTS WITH- IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION WOULD BE AT LEAST A
BILLION DOLLARS. SO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FANTASTIC WE'RE VERY HAPPY WITH
IT BUT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT INCREASES TO ONE BILLION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. SIX COLOR WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER THIRTY
THAT'S THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOU'RE HEARING MEMBERS
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE TOP
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS COMMITMENT TO
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. I
WOULDN'T BY THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PACKAGE BUT BEFORE
YOU TODAY. WORK ITEMS FOUR AND
FIVE IN THE PACKAGE IN
PARTICULAR THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANTS. OUR PRELIMINARY DATA
EVEN SHOWS THE COFFEE SERVICE
OF THE DISPUTE RESOLUTION MAY
EXCEED FIVE HUNDRED MILLION SO
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. THIS IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE TO OUR STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND ELLIE EIGHT. CAN
BE ARGUED TO THE CATHOLIC VERY
IMPORTANT FUNDING PACKAGE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. YES
BORDERLINE. TWELVE THAT'S ONE
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CLEAN A LEGO CAL
CAROLINE SWEEPING THE FAMILY
MEBERS MCCARTY AWAKE AND
WAITING WITH US THE EAST BAY
EARLY EDUCATORS AND PARENTS
VOICES LAST FRIDAY COLLECTED
YOU OUR CONCERNS ABOUT.
FUNCTION I'M STRAPPED IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THE
CORRESPONDING DOWN AB TWENTY
TWO THEY ARE HAPPY TO SEE THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS CHOI
WHERE PARENTS CAN CHOOSE
ANYTHING FOR THEIR FOUR YEAR
OLD WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT PARENT CHOICE
INCLUDE THAT ONLY PARENTS
RESPECTED THEM WHETHER THEY
HAVE A CHILD CARE SUBSIDY. I'M
STARTING FREE OF CHARGE WE HAVE
OFFERED COMPOSED AMENDMENT AND
BUDGET LANGUAGE TO ENSURE.
EQUITABLE AND UNIVERSAL
ENCRYPTION TO ACCOUNT DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. OFF THE ONE
CLEAR HOW TRIBAL COUNTERFEITING
FRANK AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSULT WITH TRIBES TO
ENSURE THEY ARE PART OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
CALL OR COME TO NUMBERS TWO
THAT'S TO TWO YOUR LINE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING JOSH ON BEHALF OF
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE. PROVIDING
COMMENTS TO AND CRITICAL TO
ENSURING AFTER TO. OF IS AFTER
TYPICAL. COLLEGES ABILITY
SIGNET BARRIER BREAKING BUT
INCOME AT THE COURSE YOU ARE.
YOU IN THE PALM SECONDARY
EDUCATION A CHALLENGE WHICH BE
ADDRESS IN BY. IN STE
UTILIZATION OF AVAIL FEDERAL
AID MANDATED SPARKING A
COMPLETION FOR WILL BE. AND THE
IS BECAUSE AFTER FOR ALL HAS
PROPOSED IMPACT THREE ON BY
LATE. THIS GRANT WOULD PROVIDE
EACH HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
COLLEGE AFTER ALL TO ENSURE CAL
CASE TWELVE THAT YOU SUPPORT
STUDENT INCOME HIGH SCHOOL G.
COURSE REQUIREMENTS IN QUALIFY
TO ATTEND THE UC OR CSU WILL
DIRECTLY OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU MUCH YOUR
COM MY- NOW CALL. ULLAL COME
FROM LINE THIRTY FOR THAT'S
THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ROSENBERGER WITH ANTI ARE YOU
OF THE HAPPENED ETP HILL ARE
YOU W. ACTING IN COLLABORATION
I DON'T EAT- WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS- DESIRE AROUND HE CAME
WOULD URGE AND I AM INCREASE OF
A COMMENT ABOUT THE RATE
INCREASE. HI TO THE BIGGER
PICTURE I WOULD URGE THAT
CONVERSATION HAPPENED BARGAIN
PEOPLE HE DOESN'T WANT 285%
THAT IS. BEING IDENTIFIED- I
WILL IN PEOPLE TWO HUNDRED OUT
OF THE BOX THERE ARE THREE AND
ONLY TALK ABOUT HE GAVE THIS
BUT WE NOT THINK ACTION TO YOUR
OWN. DELAYED ON TO ENSURE THAT
CHILD PROVIDERS ARE IN THE
PROCESS AND THEY ARE ONES THAT.
WITH PACKAGE THE BY THE FOLLOW.
I WE ALSO BUT HOLD THEM
HARMLESS DURING PERIOD OF TIME
THAT. THEY HAVE A THAT THEY
LOSE EACH YOU CALL. A PUBLICLY
THE PROPERTY HAVE COME BACK. WE
ALSO ARE DIVISION SHE SAID THAT
BECAUSE UNCLE CRIME TWENTY FOUR
HOURS BECAUSE MANY PROVIDERS
HEALTHCARE CHILDREN AFTER THE
CALL. AND USE THE PHONE BOB FOR
THAT I WELL AS SOME OF THE COME
THAT HAVE BEEN. BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FOR CHOICE AND THE AT
THE REDUCE THE- HAVE PART. ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING AFTER SCHOOL LEARNING
AND SUMMER ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. TO THE PORCH
AGAINST MENTAL HEALTH SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING. AND
ACCELERATE LEARNING OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL. BUT FACING AN ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE AND WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE CANNOT DO THAT ALONE.
THIS REQUIRES ALL HANDS ON DECK
THE PHYSICALLY WE ARE ASKING
YOU TO SET ASIDE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. FROM THE
AMERICAN ROCKY PLANNED TO BE
MADE DIRECTLY AVAILABLE FOR
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
PROVIDED COPIES LEVINE
ADJUSTMENT OR COLLAPSE FOUR
EIGHT THIS PROGRAM IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTER IF YOU THINK
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. PATH AB ELEVEN TWELVE.
AND IN FACT AT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES ACT GRANT
PROGRAM WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK AND PUBLICLY THANK
SENATOR LARRY. FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO MEET WITH
PARENTS TOMORROW EVENING
WEDNESDAY AND THE TWENTY SIX AT
FIVE THIRTY. FOR A COMMUNITY
FORUM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT COLOR
COMES ONE OF THIRTY FOR THAT
THREE FOR YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE EXPERIENCING
A DELAY. I'LL TRY THAT AGAIN
ALL RIGHT HERE NOW AND I ARE
YOU YOU MEAN I THINK CANNOT BE
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES. A MEMBER
OF THE OFFICE EQUITY CALLING
AND CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
THE FUTURE PARKING LINE ITEM
ONE WITH THE PARDON ME REVIVED
PROPOSED INCREASE OF THE- COME.
GRANT FROM VICKY 65% IN ORDER
TO THE SENATE TO ADOPT PROPOSED
RATHER THAN A MODEST INCREASE
ABOUT THE ABOUT THE CRIMINAL
GRAN AFTER BECAUSE TODAY ON
ITEM TO BE EXPENDED BURNING
GRANT WE APPRECIATE THE
PROVISION OF BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL SERVICES AND EXPANDED
FINDING OPPORTUNITIES TIME TO
PICK IT UP YOU. WE RECOMMEND
THAT ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
SERVICES FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AS WELL
PARTICULARLY DOES NOT A
RESOURCE COMMUNITY TO ARE OFTEN
LEFT OUT OF THE PARTS. THAT ARE
TARGETED FOR EARLY. AGE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AMONG NEXT. CALLER
NEXT CALL OR SOMEONE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE THAT'S THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TRINITY HALF OF CHILDREN NOW
AND COMMENTING ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THEIR
CLASS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
INVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IN ADDITION WE
NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT ACROSS A
BROAD SET OF PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO EXTEND LEARNING
INCLUDES COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
ACTUAL PROFESSIONAL TALENT
MENTORING- AND WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THIS THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE COHERENCE
ACROSS THESE PROGRAMS AND TO
PROVIDE A TRUE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOOKING LOCAL AGENT. TO THAT
END WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY THAT LINE
THE PLANNING TIMELINE AND
INTEGRATE PLANNING REQUIREMENTS
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE TO BUILD
ON THE L. CAP MODEL OF
ENGAGEMENT TO ENSURE
STAKEHOLDERS AND A CLEAR WAY TO
ENGAGE IN THE PLANNING PROCESS
AND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE WAY IN VERY
SPECIFICALLY ON SOME OF THE
FISCAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ON SO THAT WE CAN SEE HOW THE
FUNDS ARE INVESTED TO BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES.
AND FINALLY I JUST KNOW WE ARE
ALSO EXCITED TO SEE THAT THE
CORPORATE REFORM ASSIDUOUS ITEM
TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AMADA THAT'S FOURTEEN
CALLERS. HOW MANY MORE DO YOU
HAVE AND Q. WE HAVE THIRTEEN
MORE. IN Q. THE LET'S TAKE
THOSE. AND THEN WE WILL MOVE
THE- DISCUSS. FOR MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. THE COLORS LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS INSURANCE
MARKETS RESPONSES PARK AVENUE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. ORDER RIGHT TWENTY TWO
AND SIXTY FIVE- BOTH OF THEM
BEING THE NUMBER THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT COLOURS LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE THAT'S FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS HOW DO YOU KNOW
WHERE ON BEHALF OF EARLY AND
CALIFORNIA AND CALLING IN
SUPPORT AND ITEMS EIGHT NINE
AND TEN. REALLY I JUST REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE- COMMITTEE
TERMINATION. APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT SHOULD
INTERPERSONAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WHICH ALONG WITH
INCLUDING BEING QUALITY
COMPONENTS. THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN TWO DAYS I AM. SHE THE
TWENTY SECOND. YOU ACTUALLY- A
QUARTERLY LEARNING FOR THEIR
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AS WELL AS
THE A- IN OUR STATE CRITICAL.
INCREASING THE STATE OF BIRTH
RATE CRITICAL BACK COLLECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMP MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. THE COLOR IS LAW
NUMBER FOUR THAT'S FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DAVE HAS BEEN- WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING FOR SUPPORTING LEVIN
THOUSAND CHILD CARE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
WE ARE ASKING YOU TO HIT PAUSE
ON THIS PROCESS. TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND PARENTS
BEING CLUED IN THIS
PROGRAMMING. CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS WHICH STAYED OPEN
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN ANY EXPANDED
PRESCHOOL RTK PROGRAMMING
PARENTS WANT AND NEED FULL DAY
CARE AND A FULL YEAR APPEAR TO
SUSTAIN THEIR JOBS AND JOB
SEEKING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND DEDICATION
EARLY EDUCATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL. SIX
SIX COLOR SOMEONE NUMBER THREE
NINE THAT'S THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS APPLICANTS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION I
WOULD LIKE TO A MINOR COMMENTS
WITH THIS OP ED MINISTRATIONS
ON ITEMS THREE FORTY FIVE ON
THE LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH.
EARLY AND JUST COMMENT ON ITEMS
EIGHT NINE AND TEN WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ADDITION WE
ARE RECOMMENDED- WE WOULD LIKE
TO URGE OUR SUPPORT FOR ITEMS
SIX ON GTE FUNDING AS WELL. AS
THE ITEM ON A PAY DOWN ALL THE
DEFERRALS I REALIZE THAT- NOW
ITEM TWELVE AND WILL ADDRESS
THAT- UNDER THE APPROPRIATE
PROVISIONS THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR. TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A OF MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. EXPELLER COMMISSION
ONE NUMBER FORTY THAT'S FOUR
ZERO. MEMBERS YOUR AND YOUR
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
UNIVERSAL MAIL I AM TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE ESPECIALLY SIXTY
FIVE AND ONE THIRTY FOUR WE
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND I URGE
ADOPTION THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
TECHNICOLOR SOMEONE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THAT'S THREE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE RANGER
NUMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
UNDERWOOD AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FUNDING COALITION I'M GOING
THIS MORNING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FACT
RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM ONE TWO
THREE FOUR TWELVE AND FOURTEEN.
REGARDING ITEM FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANT I SUPPORTERS AS EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY SEVEN. POINT
INCLUSION OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN AFRICA. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PURPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
MODERATOR MEXICO. NEXT CALL OR
SOMEONE NUMBER FOUR EIGHT
THAT'S FOR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS NEED
TO PROCEED THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AVERAGE HOW
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PUT SITES
REALLY CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
CALLING IN REFERENCE TO ITEMS
NUMBER EIGHT NINE AND TEN FOR
NUMBER EIGHT WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PARENTAL
CHOICE PROVISION FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN G. K. ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
WE APPRECIATE THE STOCK
RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WILL
WHICH WILL ADDRESS. RENTAL
CHOICE FOR FAMILIES WITH FOUR
YEAR OLD AT THIS IS IMPERATIVE.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE- ITEM
NUMBER NINE TO INCREASE
PRESCHOOL CLASS AND WE HAVE
MANY ELIGIBLE CHILDREN THAT ARE
CURRENTLY NOT BEING SERVED AND
LASTLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE STOCK
RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM NUMBER
TEN GREAT REAR REFORM WHICH
WILL INCREASE RATES AND FABLESS
ESTATE WE AND- GREAT
REINFORCEMENT SYSTEM. WE KINDLY
REQUEST THAT THE RATE REFORM
INCREASED TO RECOMMENDED AMOUNT
OF EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF
THE TWENTY EIGHT. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ARMAR SURVEY PERCENT
OR LEYVA BILL SB FORTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NEXT CALL SOMEONE NUMBER
SIX FOURTH FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
CHAIRMAN SENATOR WERE THERE
CARVE OUT TO ELLIOTT ON THE OF
THE EARLY AND COULD. WHICH IS A
NON OR- I LIFE IN PIKE TRY CARE
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS THAT
REPRESENT A MAKESHIFT OF THE
PRIVATE PAY AN ON CARE SERVICES
THAT THE COURT FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN FROM DIVERSE CULTURAL
AND SOCIAL ECONOMIC. ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND EASY EASY MEMBERS
HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
PRE OF THE CAPACITY TO SERVE
OVER FORTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
CALLING TODAY ABOUT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL- I THINK
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF EXPANDED TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ON THE REST OF THE
MAKE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE AND
EXIST- AFTER- THIS LAST YEAR OF
COVERAGE. BUT I DO ORDER
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO I'VE TO
PUT IS THE BIG PART TO. ENSURE
THAT OTHER PROVIDERS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THESE
CHILDREN- AND COULD
POTENTIALLY- HAVE THE PARENTAL
CHOICE BUT I THINK LIKE
EVERYTHING THAT THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS THAT WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THAT ISRAEL
PARENTAL CHOICE AND PARENTS
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN HER FREE
PROGRAM OR PAINFUL OR- A FULL
DAY FULL YEAR PROGRAM THAT
WORKS BETTER FOR THEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. CALLER LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN THAT'S NINE EURO IS
OPEN. SHOULD MORNING NINE
MEMBER WILLIAM WE A HALF CARE
THE ASSOCIATION HAVE CLEARING
COLLEGE READY ORGANIZATION LIKE
THIS THIS IN STRONG SUPPORT-
ITEMS- ON GOING. TO DO FORCED
PEOPLE I THINK IN AND I'M ALSO
ON ITEM NUMBERS ON THE OF THE
TRUMP STREET. I BE WATCHING
STRONG SUPPORT ON THE INCREASE
IN THE READING GRANT. WOULD
RESPECTFUL THAT I'D BE
INTERNATIONAL BACCALAUREATE
PEOPLE BEING. IN THE LABOR-
CALLING. STUDENT CANNOT- AFFORD
THEIR SIX AND YOU AGAIN FOR OUR
FOR THE RECOMMEND GONZALEZ THE
SENATE PACKAGE ON THOSE TWO
ITEMS. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT CALL
SOMEONE NUMBER TWO THAT'S FOR
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN. JIM MODEL
HIGH ANKLE FOR START WE RECORD
THE ONE WHO FORTY HAD. SHE
BEING. OVER ONE THOUSAND KIDS
AND FAMILIES AND I'M CALLING ON
REGARDS TO I NUMBER WE ARE.
PLEASED TO SEE THE TRACK RECORD.
IN HAD START AND WE- GENE WHICH
YOU CAN HAD. IN TERMS OF BEING
A THE TABLE AND. OR THAT YOU
CAN IMPLEMENT. BEING OF COLDER
CREE. AT THE STATE BE. WE ALSO
URGE YOU TO CAN. THE EXPANSION
A FEW CAN HELP WILL WORK THAT
IN HAVE FOR PROGRAM AND WE ARE-
FOR. AT THE CORE TO DO SO SIXTY
OF HAD. CHILDREN ARE FOR OLD
AND SO SUPPORT MORE THAN THREE
THAT INCLUDES EIGHT NEW GRANT.
BY THE OFFICE OF HEAD START SO
WE ARE URGING NEED CONSIDER.
ARE YOU HELP AND YOU TO TRY
EDUCATE THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MODERATOR CALL. NEXT COLOR
SOMEONE IX ONE THE SIX YEAR
ONE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF
ASIAN ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CULTURE COLD
IN SUPPORT OF EITHER SEVEN
COLLEGE AND HIGHER AT. SHOULD
ACCEPTED FOR ALL. WE AGREE YOU
COMING DOLLAR. AND THAT TO
IMPROVE IF YOU COMPLETION WE
ALSO A TO MAKE SURE WE COULD
NOT ME TO BUILD STRONG. AND
EMIC AND FOCUS ON AMENITIES
THEIR LEARNING. AND ALLOW TO
REJECT IT YOU COURSE WHAT HAS
BEEN ALEX FUNDING IN PROPOSAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND HAVE A
GREAT. THANK YOU RINPOCHE YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR. NEXT CALL.
NEXT CALLER NUMBER NINE. THAT'S
ONE NINE LINE IS A- CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE HI. HI
THIS IS JENNY BY LAW WITHIN A
PUBLIC SCHOOLS I AM COMMENTING
ON ITEM NUMBER TWO OF THE
AGENDA I WORK WITH IN ANY
PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT WE REPRESENT
HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ARE URGING YOU TO INVEST
FEDERAL FUNDING. FOR AFTER
SCHOOL AND SUMMER ENRICHMENT
DIRECTLY IN COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
STEPPED UP SO MANY WAYS THIS
YEAR THE BIG WE WERE ASKING
YOUR SATISFIED ONE POINT ONE
BILLION FROM THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS. WE ALSO WANT YOU TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE KERR PEOPLE
FUNDING FOR ALL STATE FUNDED
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
EIGHTH AND THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY COMMUNITY LEARNING
CENTER PROGRAMS USING PROP
NINETY EIGHT NINETEEN AND
FINALLY WE URGE YOU TO PASS AB
ELEVEN TWELVE WHICH WILL
STABILIZE AFTER SCHOOL AND
SUMMER PROGRAMS. BY CREATING A
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN FUNDING
FORMULA THANK OU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR THIS.
IS THE THIRTEENTH CALL COMING
UP. THAT IS CORRECT BELITTLING
NUMBER SIXTY. THAT SIX SIX ZERO
ONE IS A- THANK YOU TO ME WHY
YOU MIGHT ASK YEAH YOU WERE
VERY. OF THAT BEING MADE IN
ITEM ONE INCLUDING A YOUR BATH.
IN THE CLIENT BAPPI BY UP
HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION ONLY. IN WHERE BUT
AGE. BEEN CREDIBLY IMPORT AWARE
OF THE AND THEN THE- HAVE WELL
AS THE CHANGES MAY UNDER I.
WHEN YOU FIRST BREAK TO ADDRESS
THE TEAM. HERE THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARM IN. ARM WITH.
THAT THOSE WERE THE COMMENTS ON
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TEN. AND EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS OUR THIRTEENTH
HEARING AND WE HAVE HAD TWELVE
HEARINGS IN WHICH WE HAVE ERRED
THIS EXTENSIVELY. AND WE HAVE
TAKEN HUNDREDS OF COMMENTS. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A CHANCE TO
THE PUBLIC TO MAKE. ANY
COMMENTS ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
THAT ARE ALSO ON THE AGENDA I
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
COMBINED THOSE TWO BUT- WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT. AND SO. I'M
GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THIS ROOM R. THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WISHES TO ADDRESS
PHOTO MONEY. C. NON WILL TO
ROME TWO. C. NINE MODERATOR-
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO YOU
AND THIS IS JUST VOTE ONLY AND
ARE IF YOU LET ME KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN QUEUE I MIGHT.
SEE IF I HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
WOMEN'S. YES AS A REMINDER PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE YOUR
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THE SIX I
HAVE AN Q. CURRENTLY WERE
QUEUED UP BEFORE YOU MADE YOUR-
COMMENT ABOUT VOTE ONLY. SO I
DO NOT KNOW IF THESE ARE FOR
VOTE ONLY OR IF THEY'RE STILL
TRYING TO COMMENT ON WHY MEANS
ONE THROUGH TEN WELL WE'LL GO
TO LINE. LET'S TAKE THESE
CLASSICS EITHER WAY BECAUSE IF
I HAD UNDERSTOOD I WOULD HAVE.
PUT THE TWO TOGETHER AT THE
BEGINNING ANYWAY SO LET'S TAKE
THE SIX AND SEE IF THERE'S A
LINE AFTERWARDS. UNDERSTOOD
WHAT A LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
THAT SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TOM LAWRENCE EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- IN ADDITION TO OUR
LETTER THAT WE SENT LAST WEEK
TO THE COMMUNITY DOCTOR LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR ITEM
TWENTY FOUR BE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AMERICANS
PROGRAMS AND WE THINK IT'S FAST
FOR INCLUDING- RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT. EMPLOYEES PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM DURING THE
PANDEMIC WILL NOT. BE ELIGIBLE
FOR- BY CHANGE IT THE SCHOOL
YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT
CALL. NEXT CALLER SOMEONE
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE THAT'S
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S JAMES MOSES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
THE EDUCATION OF CHILDREN
COMMENTING ON THE ISLAND'S
EIGHT NINE AND TEN WE
APPRECIATE BOTH THE CHANGES.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION TO INCLUDE- PERSONAL
CHOICE WE ARE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCREASE IN
THE CSPD SLOTKIN'S MENTIONED
EARLIER WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF CHILDREN- UNDERSERVED
AND I'M SURE WE'LL CREATION OF
THAT. AND WE ALSO WANT TO
COMMENT ON NUMBER TEN- I'M
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATIVE OF MY
SENATOR- JEWEL BEAUCOUP IS
SUPPORTING AND OFFERING. SB TWO
FORTY SIX TO INCREASE RATES
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND CHILD CARE SYSTEM
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THAT ITEM AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
SURE CENTER- TROUBLED
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AS
WELL. MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THE
COLORS NUMBERS FOR THAT'S FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL ALL
RIGHT. CALIFORNIA I AM NOT A
MAN COULD BE IN A CONTACT. I DO
SUPPORT FOR SPECIAL VERY
RECOVERY GRANT. DEPENDING IN
YOUR BOOK ONE OF THOSE CHANGES
VERY VERY. THEY'RE ACCESS TO
SUPPORT SERVICES I'M GREAT WHAT
DO YOU DO FUNDING ANY THE SUPER
COOL- THAT BEEN ASSIGNED JUST A
EDUCATION AND THEN THEY
REALIZED OUR INTEREST FOR MANY
YEAH IN A STARTED TO ALLEVIATE
THAT. YOU SHOULD TO ENSURE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITY OR
ANYTHING THANK AND THERE IS A
CALL SERVICES THEY DID NOT
DURING CLOTHES. THANK YOU FOR
YOU WE HAVE. YOUR COMMENT
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. OUR NEXT
CALLER'S FROM LINE AND SEVENTY
THAT SEVEN FIVE YOU'RE ONE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE CHAIR AND CALL WITH MERRY
CAL AND MY MIKE ON THE
REGARDING SIX FIVE MAKER YOU
MEAL. WE WANNA THINK THEY CAN
PROJECT THE MAY REVISION FOR TO
MAKE CREEK ONGOING IN IT'S
GOING TO. AND PERSONAL TO
CONSIDER IN. IN MAKING ALLEGE
FOR. ET AT THE FUNDAMENTAL
COULD OF THE COPY AND PERMANENT
APPROACH UNIVERSE PRESCHOOL
MEAL CAL. WHICH STREET TO DATA
VEHICLE BURKE A FISCALLY. WAY
FOUR THOUSAND MORE SCHOOL CUT
AS MANY AS TWO MILLION MORE
STUDENTS- MAXIMIZING IS AN
EQUITABLE SCALABLE AND
EFFICIENT INVESTMENT OF STATE
DOLLARS THEY CAN DRAW DOWN AND
HE FOR ONE FEDERAL MATCH AND IF
WE ACT THIS YEAR WITHOUT
QUESTION EDICAL PEOPLE TO
UNFORTUNATELY ELEVATED. WE CAN
MAKE THE MOST OF AVAILABLE
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE
THAT KIDS MOST IN NEED OF PRE
COLONIAL ARE WELL NOURISHED
READY TO LEARN ABLE TO THRIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
CALLER SOMEONE NUMBER TWO SEVEN
THAT'S TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE OPEN.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
INTERNET PELLETIER I'M THE
ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT
CRISTINA CAN'T COUNTIES HELP
ACTION I'M CALLING ABOUT ITEM
NUMBER ONE FIVE FIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION OUT OF HOME FINDING.
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
AND GRATITUDE THAT ADJUSTMENT
THE OUTCOME HERE FOR NO EXTRA
MONEY IN IN THE WORK. AND THAT
THEY ARE DOLLARS THAT BECAUSE
THE DOLLARS NEED TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE NOW NOT
WHERE THEY WERE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
FIREEYE CONCERNS THE PROPOSED
AMOUNTS ARE QUITE LOW NOW IS
THE TIME TO MAINTAIN OR
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH I HOPE THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WILL ENSURE YOU
MOST IN CRISIS ARE SUPPORTED TO
SIXTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
COLORS ARE MY NUMBER TWENTY.
THAT'S TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING AGAIN YOUR
BILL IF YOU WITH THAT PLACE THE
TWENTY REITERATE WITH RESPECT
TO THE- A TO BUY DOWN THE
DEFERRALS AND STRONGLY SUPPORT.
FISH AND THE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE BILLION BASE
FUNDING GOING FORWARD WHEN THE
FEDERAL FUNDS DROP OFF TO THE-
STRONG SUPPORT BUYING ON ALL K.
TWELVE DIFFERENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MODERATOR THAT WAS
THE SIX CALLERS. HOW MANY MORE
OR IN Q. WE AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
THAT HAVE QUEUED UP SINCE THAT
TIME SIR THEN WILL TAKE THOSE
SEVEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
CALLER IS A LINE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO BEDS TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS TERRY CAN COMMENTING ON
ITEM THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE A
COMPREHENSIVE CHILDREN'S AGENCY
IN LOS ANGELES WE APPLIED TO
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS OR CAN YOU
SCHOOLS. THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INTEGRATING
NON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
THE COMMUTER PARTNERSHIP GRANTS
PROGRAM IN THE NEED REVISED
NONPROFITS LIKE CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE ARE CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF CAN YOU SCHOOLS. ARE
COMMON FORM APPROACH WE
TRANSFORM SCHOOL CULTURE AND
CLIMATE CENTERING A WHOLE CHILD
AND FAMILY WELL BEING AND
SUCCESS. WE SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT STATEWIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
COORDINATING COHESIVE SYSTEM OF
LEARNING IN PRACTICE- CAN YOU
SCHOOLS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE CAN
SURE OPPORTUNITIES FOR NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS. TO
SERVICE CAN YOU SCHOOL LEAD
APPLICANTS OR SUBCONTRACTOR
PARTNERS UNDER THE GRANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE UBLIC
COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
CALL IS FROM NUMBERS THREE
THAT'S THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND ONE THREE TWO YEARS
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM TE
CUBAN MODEL UNTIL I NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING JENNY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. YOUR
MAIN VERY EXCITED THAT THE NAY
REVISED INCLUDED I REQUEST FOR
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE CREATION
OF AN LGBTQ PLUS TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF. THE
REQUESTED AN ITEM FIFTY THREE
AND ONE OH SEVEN BOTH ARE
CRITICAL PIECES TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROVE BOTH- WE ALSO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENACT THE
FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. SIX COLORS FROM NUMBER
EIGHTY THAT EIGHT ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THEY'RE NOT BE A
PUBLIC ADVOCATES COMMENTING ON
ITEM THIRTY FIVE WE URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
INCLUDED IN A REVISED AT LEAST
5% OF THE TIME SHE GOT HER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE INCLUDING
EXPANDING THE EIGHT REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND
PROVIDING FUNDING TO SCALE
SERVICES OF THE WIDE REGIONAL
LOCAL TV PROVIDER FURTHER WALK
COMMUNITIES GOLDEN COMPASS SOME
OF THE HEALTHY CIRCLE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ARE GROUNDED IN THE
TRANSFORMATIVE SYSTEMS CHANGE
MODEL THAT IS LACKING FROM
HEALTHY START INSTEAD COMMUNITY
FOR SHOULD BE ALIGNED TO THE
FOUR PILLARS OF COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AT THE TIME OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR FREE BUT- I'M
REFLECT THE NEEDS AND VALUES OF
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE A
DETERMINES OUR COMMUNITY
VISIONING PROCESS AND TOGETHER
WITH PARENTS STUDENTS.
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTRATORS
ADDITIONALLY ADDED WEIGHT TO BE
GIVEN TO THE APPLICANTS POVERTY
STATUS TO ENSURE THE NEEDIEST
COMMUNITIES ARE PRIORITIZED. WE
DO SUPPORT EXTENDING THE USE
THE FUNDS TO TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT TO ALLOW TIME FOR GRANT
RECIPIENTS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER TO BUILD
CAPACITY AND SUSTAINABLE I
THINK ST THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF A MODERATOR NEXT
COURT. NEXT CALL OR SOMEONE
EIGHTY. THAT EIGHT ONE YOUR IS
OPEN. HI IS ANDREA TO STRUM
HEAVY VIEW OF THE- CAN YOU HEAR
ME. CLEARLY WELL- EXCELLENT.
THANK I'VE BEEN IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. AND I WILL DIE MAKE
USE OF MY VERY J. SIXTY
SECONDS. SO I JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT I THINK WITH THESE CALLERS
SAYING ABOUT. DOUBLING THE
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL ED
CHILDREN FROM FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO A BILLION MAKES A
GREAT DEAL OF SENSE SO MAYBE
INSTEAD OF DEMOLISHING THE
PERFECTLY GOOD. CAPITOL ANNEX
BUILDING TO THE TUNE OF A
BILLION DOLLAR DOLLARS SO YOU
SENATORS CAN HAVE BETTER
OFFICES. MAYBE YOU COULD
CONSIDER INVESTING BACK IN THE
CHILDREN INSTEAD BECAUSE AFTER
ALL YOU HURT THEM YOU HURT THEM
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC PLEASE
STAND DEMOCRATS PLAN TO MAKE.
THE KIND OF **** YOU USUALLY
PASSED LIKE TWO SEVEN SIX HOUSE
PEOPLE FLEEING CALIFORNIA.
FLEEING CALIFORNIA WITH THEIR
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF MEDICAL
MANDATE. SO GET YOUR PRIORITIES
STRAIGHT YOU WORK FOR US YOU
DON'T NEED BIGGER OFFICES YOU
DON'T NEED TO DEMOLISH THE
BUILDING. AND YOU SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
AFTER HONORING THAT SUPERMAN
IS. THAT CEMENTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. SIX
DOLLARS ON EIGHTY THAT EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE OPEN. ARE YOU
DISABILITIES HERE WHICH WERE
COUNTY ARE THAT- WE LOOK WANTED
TO I WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS- IN PARTICULAR
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
SELFLESS ON. ITEM NUMBERS FOR-
AND ALSO REQUESTING FOR A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
RATHER THAN THE PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. AND ALIGNING
OUR COMMENTS WITH EARLY EDGE ON
ITEMS EIGHT TO TEN- AND FUNDING
UNIVERSAL PTA AND ALSO THE
ADDITIONAL BOX FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND- DIRECTOR FOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
MODERATOR I SHOW THIS IS THE.
SEVENTH CALLER COMING UP.
CORRECTIVE IS OUR FINAL WARNING
QUEUE AS WELL THINGS WHY NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN AT EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THANK
YOU. YEAH DOROTHY STEWART FROM
OLD BARNWELL. I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT CARE PROVIDER I TO COME
IN AND ITEM EIGHT. WITHOUT A
MAKES A REALLY SYSTEM PRIVATE
CHILD CARE MARKET WILL BE
DECIMATED WE REALLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. THANK YOU WITH THE
NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM. G. K.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
pREALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. AND MODERATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
UNDER TRYING MOMENTS AND- WE
HAD FORTY DIFFERENT COLORS. AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE. THAT SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BRING. THIS
WE'RE GOING TO BE THE MATTER
BACK. THE COMMITTEE. IN OUR WE
HAVE. IS I DO HAVE A LIST. OF
FROM. SENATOR CHOI BOGUE OF THE
ITEMS THAT- ON PART A THAT SHE
WISHES TO EITHER OF THE STATE
VOTE NO. AND SO- I HAVE
SEGMENTED THOSE OUT SO IT
APPEARS AND WILL GIVE A CHANCE
FOR CORRECTIONS TO BE MADE. IT
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE- UNANIMITY
ON ITEMS THREE TO SEVEN NINE
THROUGH TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE THROUGH. TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY THREE SIXTY ONE SIXTY
THREE THROUGH ONE ELEVEN. ONE
THIRTEEN THROUGH ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH
ONE FORTY ONE. 441-404-1406
THROUGH ONE FORTY NINE. AND ONE
FIFTY ONE THROUGH ONE EIGHTY
FOUR AND SO I WOULD ASK IF
THERE IS A MOTION ON THOSE
ITEMS- YES SOME OF THE MOTION
BY MEN- AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
WAS A CORRECT RECITAL HERE.
RIGHT OKAY THEN I WOULD ASK FOR
A ROLL CALL- ON THAT AGGREGATE
A MOTION OF THOSE ITEMS.
SENATOR LED BY SENATOR MAN BY
AND THERE ARE TROUBLED. THE
MOTION CARRIES THREE ZERO AND
THEN THE OF THE NEXT LIST OF
ITEMS WHICH WOULD ROUND OUT
EVERYTHING IN AGENDA PART A
WOULD BE ITEMS. ONE TWO EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINE SIXTY
TWO ONE TWELVE ONE THIRTY FIVE
ONE THIRTY SIX ONE THIRTY SEVEN
ONE FORTY TO ONE FORTY FIVE AND
ONE FIFTY AND SO I WOULD ASK IF
THERE IS A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON THE
OUTSIDE SOME OF MOTION BY
SENATOR MAN. I THEN WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EARLIER
BY SENATOR MEANT LIFE AND OUR
JOB OF. THE NEXT THING AND OKAY
THAT IS- NOT VOTING. SO THERE
ARE THOSE THAT MOTION CARRIES
AND THEN WHEN WE MOVED TO.
AGENDA PART B. I THINK WE MIGHT
DO THIS AND THREE THINGS THE
ERRORS VOTE ON WAYS IN WHICH
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT THERE
MIGHT BE A MOTION ON A COUPLE
OF ITEMS AFTER THAT AND THEN
THERE WOULD BE A MOTION ON.
OTHER ITEMS THAT THERE MIGHT
NOT BE A UNANIMOUS VOTE SO THE
ITEMS ON WHICH I BELIEVE.
THERE'S AGREEMENT AND COULD BE
TAKEN IN ONE MOTION ARE THE
LIBRARY ISSUES ONE THROUGH
FIFTEEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ISSUES ONE THROUGH
EIGHT TEN THROUGH. TWELVE
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY ISSUES ONE THROUGH
THREE FIVE THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
ISSUES ONE AND TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ISSUES ONE THROUGH
THIRTY EIGHT AND FORTY THROUGH
FORTY NINE. AND STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE AN OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH ISSUES ONE
THROUGH THREE. ARM SO IS THERE
A MOTION ON THOSE SIDE OF THIS
MOTION BY SENATOR MAN. SO ON
THE ITEMS THAT I JUST READ
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR LAND HI SENATOR MEANT.
HI SENATOR A TROUBLED. THAT
MOTION IS APPROVED THREE TO
ZERO. AND THEN SENATE ROADSHOW
ABOVE DID I UNDERSTAND YOU
MIGHT WANT TO MAKE A MOTION ON
A COUPLE OF ITEMS OR DO YOU
WANT ME TO JUST DO THE REST OF
WHICH WAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO.
THE WASHINGTON. OPEN THE UC
ISSUE NUMBER NINE AND CSU ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. OKAY THE LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. OKAY THEN-
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL ON THAT
MOTION- LAND NO SENATOR MEN.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF I STAND.
THERE NOT VOTING. YOU HAVE A
CALL CENTER- TROUBLED CRY
SENATOR TO ABOUT. THAT MOTION
FAILS ONE TO ONE. AND SO NOW-
THAT WOULD LEAVE THE REMAINING
ITEMS INCLUDING THOSE TWO ON
WHICH THERE'S NOT UNANIMITY. OF
PALM ED TO PROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT WOULD
BE UC ISSUES NINE THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN CSU ISSUE FOR AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISSUES THIRTY
NINE AND FIFTY YEARS THEIR
MOTION TO APPROVE THOSE ISSUES.
MOVED BY SENATOR MATH- WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR LAND BY SENATOR MAN ALL
RIGHT SENATOR OF TROUBLED. I
BELIEVE IN THE- THAT'S AN
VOTING YES SO MOTION CARRIES. A
THAT COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS BUT
AS USUAL WE ALWAYS OFFER OUR
CLOSING COMMENTS AND I THINK
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME OF OUR
AFTER THIS ACTION. IN I THINK
FIRST A LITTLE CONTEXT THAN IT
ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS ABOUT
THIS IS WHEN YOU HAVE HUNDREDS
OF INDIVIDUAL ITEMS YOU SEE THE
ITEMS INDIVIDUALLY BUT THEY
REALLY FIT INTO A LARGER
ARCHITECTURE AND THERE ARE MUCH
AS MUCH ABOUT THE ARCHITECTURE
IS ABOUT THE ITEMS AND SO. IF
YOU LOOK AT WORKING OFF THE MAY
REVISION. WE REJECTED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
CORPORATE TARGETED INTERVENTION
GRANTS REJECTED THE TWO BILLION
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY GRANTS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION OF TARGETED
INTERVENTION GRANTS ONE BILLION
FROM COMMUNITY SCHOOLS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. FROM EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANTS AND
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION ROUGHLY.
FROM THE TEACHER PACKAGE AND SO
THOSE TOTAL SIX POINT SIX
BILLION AND THEN THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL BASED ON THE MAY
REVISED THAT WE HEARD EARLIER.
ANOTHER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ASSUMING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST REVENUES WHICH REALLY
ALLOWED FOR SEVEN POINT SEVEN
BILLION OF ROOM IN THE BUDGET.
AND SO THEN WE TO IN THE
ACTIONS WE JUST TALK. WE USED
TWO POINT SIX BILLION OF THAT
TO PAY OFF THE DEFERRALS WE USE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR THE-
ARPAD THE FIXING THE EXPANDED
LEARNING AFTER SCHOOL- ITEM.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
BASE INCREASE ONE BILLION OTHER
SPECIAL EDUCATION RELATED
SUPPLEMENTS SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION FOUR. THE AG HIGH
SCHOOL COMPLETION GRANTS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANTS. AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR MILLION
FOR STAGE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AND
RATES AND THERE WERE A FEW
THINGS SUCH AS CO INCREASES.
AND IF YOU PUT THAT TOGETHER
FOR THE TO PACKAGE IS VOTE
CATER TO AND HIGH RIDGE. IT
REALLY ADDRESSES WHAT CAME UP
FROM THIS COMMITTEE ON PAYING
OFF THE DEFERRALS DON'T WHITE
TOLD ECONOMIC DOWNTURN TO PAY
OFF DEBT- DO IT NOW. A PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS BOTH
ONE TIME AND ONGOING AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION UP IMPROVE
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENTS
AND SUPPORTING STUDENTS WITH
ADDITIONAL AFTER SCHOOL CARE
AND ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES BY
ENSURING THAT MORE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SUPPORTS AND MAKE OTHER KEY
INVESTMENTS IN UNIVERSAL CHILD
NUTRITION A. G. COMPLETION IN
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
AND CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
AMONG. A MANY THINGS IN THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL TOGETHER WITH THE RATE
AND SLIGHT INCREASES IN THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM R. TWO
BUILDING BLOCKS TOWARD A MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR ALL OF OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN OTHER
SYSTEM WILL BE HEARD TOMORROW
IN SUB THREE AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER ON THE AGENDA. ON
HIGHER EDUCATION THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SECTION PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INSTABILITY
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES PRIME
PROVIDING A 5% BASE INCREASE
ABOVE THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LEVELS EXTENDING THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BY ONE YEAR THE FISCAL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE SENATE THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN SUPPORT FOR
SERVICES THAT HELP STUDENTS
SUCCEED IN THEIR EDUCATION
WHETHER IT'S- MO JO MACE A
POINT TODAY- EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES SAY PEP. INCREASE
FUNDING FOR EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAMS AND WE
ALSO MAKE LARGE INVESTMENTS AND
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY BY INVESTING SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION AND PART TIME
FACULTY OFFICE HOURS AND
COMPENSATION. AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY AT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
WOULD BRING THE STATE CLOSER TO
REACHING THE GOAL. THAT 75% OF
INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE DELIVERED
BY FULL TIME FACULTY AND
THERE'S ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS. IN
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM A
SUCH AS FINANCIAL AID RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT OUR
PRIORITIES OF THE SENATE. THAT
WEREN'T HEARD TODAY BUT WILL BE
HEARD IN THE FALL BUDGET
COMMITTEE NEXT WEEK AND SO. THE
FACT THAT A FEW THINGS WORK
HERE- BUT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED AND NOT GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED OUR WHEN WE COME OUT
OF THIS BUDGET SO. ARM I WANT
TO BUT BEFORE. HI AS FOR ANY
COMMENTS CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR MEN AND SENATE RETRO
BOAT. THANK EVERYONE THE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THAT
TESTIFIED TO HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
THAT ATTENDED OUR THIRTEEN
HEARINGS AND GAVE US FEEDBACK.
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE
MET WITH OUR BECAUSE WE MET HAD
COUNTLESS COUNTLESS MEETINGS
WITH STUDENTS FACULTY PARENTS.
OF HANDS- MANAGERS OF EVERY
LEVEL OF SCHOOL SYSTEM AND HAVE
WORKED THROUGH THORNY ISSUES
AND WHILE THE FINAL BUDGET
MIGHT REFINE THIS MORE IN THE
GOVERNOR WILL WEIGH IN IN
CERTAIN WAYS. I THINK THIS IS A
STRONG BASE. THE SORT OF TAKE
WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS FISCAL
SITUATION BUDGET FOR IMPACT AND
FILL IN HOLES ACROSS THE BUDGET
SOME VERY PLEASED OF WITH THIS
OUTCOME. LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE ANY CLOSING STATEMENTS
SENATOR MEN AND THEN CENTER-
TROUBLE. THANK YOU CAN AMERICA-
THE IS. WE'RE NEAR THE END OF
GUESS MY FIRST BUT SEASON IS
ALLEGED. AND I WILL SAY IT'S
BEEN INTERESTING GETTING A
GLIMPSE OF HOW THE SAUSAGE IS
MADE- YOU KNOW I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON SHERMAN THERE'S POINT
ABOUT THE ARCHITECTURE THERE
ARE. ITEMS IN THIS PACKAGE
THAT. I THOUGHT I MIGHT NOT
HAVE. PICTORAL CHOSEN FROM
SCRATCH BUT OVERALL I THINK THE
DIRECTION OF THIS- BUDGET FOR.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION K.
THROUGH TWELVE IN HIGHER ED IS
A VERY VERY STRONG PACKAGE- AND
ONE I VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW I THINK FOR ME MOST
IMPORTANT WAS THAT WE- PAID OFF
THE DEFERRALS AND RESTORE THE
CUTS TO HIGHER EDUCATION- THOSE
AT AND GAVE AN ADDITIONAL COAL
INCREASE I THINK THAT HAS TO BE
THE BASELINE- WELL I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S AN URGE TO EARMARK
FUNDS FOR PARTICULAR PROGRAMS.
I THINK PRINCIPLES OF FISSION
SEEM LOCAL CONTROL DICTATE THAT
WE TRY TO GIVE THOSE IN WHO
KNOW THE DETAILS OF EDUCATION
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THE ALLEY
AS- YOU COP IN THE CSU SYSTEM
AND THEIR CAMPUSES- THE FUNDING
AND FLEXIBILITY TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS
APPROPRIATELY AND I THINK THIS
BUDGET DOES A LOT OF THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S VERY APPROPRIATE-
AND I GUESS I JUST. EMPHASIZE
THE BROADER POINT HERE WHICH IS
THIS IS A MASSIVE INVESTMENT
EDUCATION AND THAT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE. OUR
ECONOMY TODAY THE FACT THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH VERY VERY
HIGH TAX REVENUES THAT WE HAVE
AN ECONOMY THAT'S WITHSTOOD A
GENERATIONAL PANDEMIC IS DUE IN
LARGE PART TO THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE MADE IN EDUCATION THE
PAST. BOTH OF THE CATO TWELVE
LEVEL AND I'M A PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
MYSELF I AND I WENT TO AN
EXCELLENT PUBLIC SCHOOL AND WE
SHOULD OFFER THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO EVERY YOUNG
CHILD HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
ALSO OBVIOUSLY IN RCS USED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN HOUSTON
UC'S WHICH ARE PROVIDED SO MUCH
OF THE RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
THAT HAS BEEN THE FOUNDATION
FOR ALL OUR KNOWLEDGE ECONOMY
IN THE STATE AND SO I I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THIS BUDGET I'M
EXCITED ABOUT OUR INVESTMENT IN-EDUCATION AND I HOPE THAT THIS.
CONTINUES TO MARK A TREND WHERE
WE DON'T DE EMPHASIZING NEGLECT
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A SENATE
ROADSHOW BLOKE. HELLO GOOD. M.
THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORT. AS
MISTER CHAIR. TO SPEAK. I WON A
JUST SHARE THE SAME COMMON SAYS
MY FELLOW FRESHMAN SENATOR
ASKING HER TO MEAN. THE FIRST
TIME. A SITTING IN THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE WITH CENTER LAYERED
AND I HAVE TO SAY IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE SERVING WITH BOTH OF
YOU AND HEARING YOUR FEEDBACK.
ON TO- SPECIALLY YUR
EXPERIENCE AND ALERT OF TRULY
APPRECIATE. VERY MUCH WHAT YOU
HAVE HAD TO OFFER AND YOUR
COUNCIL- THAT IN MIND I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE- IT. THIS IS
A VERY GENEROUS- PROPOSAL AND
I'M VERY EXCITED TO SEE A LOT
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN THE
FUNDING THAT WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH. I WITH THAT I DO
WANT IT JUST GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF. JUST COUNCIL TO EVERYONE TO
ALL OF OUR- STAKEHOLDERS ON IN
THIS BUDGET AND NASA ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT WITH THIS
THESE MONIES ARE BEING ASKED I
PROVIDED- GIVEN. THAT THAT WE
TAKE VERY VERY GOOD CARE OF THE
FUNDS AND HOW WE AB WE UTILIZE
THEM TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
UTILIZE THEM IN THE INTENT IN
WHICH THEY ARE. BEING PROVIDED
AND THAT WE KEEP TRACK OF THE
SUCCESSES OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE ARE OFFERING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ARE TRULY- UTILIZING
THEM THAT THE MONEY'S IN A WAY
WHERE I AM THEY WILL. SHOW
SUCCESS AND IF THEY'RE NOT TO
HAVE THE HONEST CONVERSATIONS
LAST YEAR OKAY LET'S THREE
DIRECT AN INCH AND CHANGED
COURSE OF COURSE OF ACTION. SO
I JUST I WANTED TO JUST GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF FEEDING TO- TO
COUNTERVAILING. AND WISHING
EVERYBODY MUCH SUCCESS MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU CENTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I SHOULD MAKE
THE OFTEN COMMENTED. A WASN'T
BAD WORK FOR THREE FRESHMEN
LEGISLATORS- A AND IT- LET ME
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE OT
ABLE TO TESTIFY. YOU STILL
COULD SUBMIT COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
AND SINCE FINAL ACTION WILL
STILL BE TAKEN. BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON THIS. ALL THESE
ITEMS ARE STILL RIPE A SO YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. A WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WITH
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.